El otro día, Pizzarritas, hablamos de jugadores más bonitos que buenos.
Hoy le damos la vuelta.
Vamos con futbolistas más efectivos que estéticos.
¿Qué pasa, Pizzarritas?
Normalmente se suele decir eso de este jugador es más bonito que bueno,
no es una crítica velada,
pero hoy le vamos a dar la vuelta para hablar de esos futbolistas
que quizás estéticamente, visualmente no nos llenan demasiado los ojos,
no llenan demasiado los highlights, pero que son tremendamente buenos.
Yo le he estado dando vueltas, chicos.
Qué tal, Adri, Alex, Nao, ¿cómo estáis?
Qué tal.
Qué tal. Y me ha costado.
Me cuesta ver.
Es chungo, porque al final los que son buenos
tienen cosas muy bonitas, por cualquier razón.
O sea, un jugador que golpea muy bien el balón, un regateador, un gran portero.
Es complicado coger casos,
pero me ha salido una lista chula que, si os parece, inauguro con el jugador
que primero me vino a la mente.
Pedro Rodríguez.
Pedro era un jugador que no te llenaba visualmente, era rápido.
Sí, pero tenías que descifrarle, tenías que entender cómo jugaba,
entender su valor.
Un jugador luego que ha hecho muchas cifras sin tener ningún
como se dice en Estados Unidos, signature move, ninguna jugada.
Y me parece ese ejemplo perfecto de ser mucho más bueno que bonito.
Y encima vigente. Claro.
Yo esto lo considero un elogio, lo considero un elogio, porque creo que a Pedro,
se le llegó a infravalorar por esto,
porque no te entraba rápido por el ojo, aunque se le veía muy bueno.
Tiene un signature move de Pedrito la frontal.
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Ehh, en esa escuela.
De esa escuela yo creo que es fácil tirar del hilo y salen unos cuantos.
¿A qué llamáis escuela? Escuela Canarias.
Delantero esforzado, delantero esforzado.
Yo, bueno, yo tiraba por cantera a Barça,
porque a mí me con esto que has comentado de Pedro me viene a la cabeza.
Yo creo nuestras primeras sensaciones quizá cuando salió Cuenca.
Pero Cuenca era al revés.
Cuenca era más bonito que bueno, no?
Yo yo yo creo que Cuenca bonito.
La guardiola, no? Yo creo que Cuenca bonito.
No vamos a ver.
Hay jugadores que no son ni bonitos ni buenos.
Claro, claro. Cuando salió era bueno.
Ostras, fue titular en aquel Barça durante bastante tiempo.
Bueno, durante un tiempo dijimos oye, Cuenca existe.
Guardiola dijo que no era bonito.
Creo que hay nombres mejores. Creo que hay nombres.
No, bueno, sí, sí.
Yo no, no, este no estaba en mi lista.
He dicho que a raíz de lo que has comentado.
¿Quieres que hablemos de Jeffren?
No.
Yo tengo, venga, salto yo, salto yo el mío.
El el mejor que tengo de la lista.
Es verdad, es verdad que ha tenido detalles preciosos en su carrera.
Te lo adivino.
¿Quién es?
F.M.
No, no, no.
¿Quién es F.M.?
Ferland Mendy.
No, no.
Creía que estaba hablando de las ruletas de Ferland Mendy en salida balón.
Ferland Mendy es más bueno que bonito.
Este es un ejemplo clarísimo.
Yo veo a uno muchísimo mejor.
Hablamos de uno de los mejores de siempre.
Fuera del área, el tipo se trastabella siempre.
No es un delantero bonito,
pero es que se la lleva siempre que lo intenta.
Luis Alberto Suárez.
Bueno.
Es mucho más bueno que bonito.
Estoy de acuerdo.
No es...
Claro, tiene mucha más técnica.
Las definiciones, sí, ojo, he dicho que tiene definiciones supertores.
Pero estoy de acuerdo.
Pero es un delantero bonito.
Estoy de acuerdo.
Pero hay jugadores...
Bastante más feos.
Yo iba a decir que Luis Suárez...
Claro.
Ahora...
O sea, Luis Suárez de ahora...
Es bueno, porque sigue siendo bueno en la definición,
pero si tenía algo de preciosidad, la ha perdido.
A ver, yo creo que el Suárez más bonito
era el inicial.
Esto se suele decir siempre, ¿no?
Pero a mí era cuando jugaba en banda o en los años en Liverpool.
Yo estoy de acuerdo con lo que dice, porque...
No era muy fino o no parecía muy fino.
Esto se habla más de parecer que otra cosa, pero era tremendo.
Se escapa un control.
No tiene una carrera especialmente fea.
O sea, una carrera de forma de correr, quiero decir.
La carrera de Suárez...
Y ese recorte de este...
Pero es que lo va a hacer toda la vida.
Es buenísimo.
Claro, pero ese recorte el que dices tú...
Pero es feo, no es feo.
Pero es mucho más bueno que bonito.
Mira, mira.
Un ejemplo.
Pero es que... ¿Qué decir?
No te parece...
Un jugador más bueno que bonito, creo que hay muchos en general.
Pero no te parece que aquí...
Pero tiene que ser especialmente feo.
Vale. O sea, no te encaja Haaland,
porque lo tenía también a Haaland.
Yo tengo un nombre polémico.
Haaland es... Haaland...
Un poco más que Suárez, claro, es que...
Un poco más que Suárez.
Nao, tu ejemplo perfecto.
La escuela uruguaya se presta mucho a este vídeo.
Sí, es verdad.
Eso es verdad.
El amigo Federico Albert de Ipeta también es mucho más bueno que bonito.
Yo creo que es fácil ir al jugador sacrificado.
Sí, es más de rol ahí, sí, estoy de acuerdo.
En mi caso, yo jugaba mucho a la Play con mis tíos
y estaban enamorados del Milan del 2005.
Hombre, claro.
Tiene una canción, la han dedicado a una canción.
Sí, muy buena, muy buena.
Yo esa canción algún día la usaré para algo.
Brutal.
Es buenísima.
La canción viene a decir...
Para tu casamiento.
No he visto a nadie tan guapo como tú desde el Milan del 2005.
Pero bueno, en inglés y con ritmo, muy top.
No lo hemos imaginado, Alex, la verdad.
El gran exponente...
Como mi tío Mauricio está loco, tiene un nidilio con este futbolista.
Uno de los jugadores favoritos también de Carl Ancelotti.
Estamos hablando del Pippo Insabi.
Ah, buenísimo.
No, sí, sí.
Buenísimo, buenísimo.
Muy buen ejemplo.
De hecho, yo en ese perfil tenía un jugador que creo que nos encanta a los cuatro,
pero que es ese perfil ratonero
y que desde luego...
Es que me hacía mucha gracia porque hasta celebraba feo.
Tomás Müller.
Sí, hombre, sí, sí, lo tengo.
Lo había contemplado también a la vida de Tomás.
Müller es paradigmático en esta.
Me hace mucha gracia porque Müller marca un golazo y siempre celebra.
Es como las celebraciones...
Los vídeos estos que hacen celebración...
¿Cómo celebraría un gol un jugador en 1960?
Y van corriendo así, ¿no?
Tomás Müller, macho.
Tal cual.
Para qué vas a pensar una decencia.
Yo tengo un triple, a ver qué os parece en este aspecto.
Que es...
Va a decir Neymar, el cabrón.
Otra vez.
Declan Rice.
Sí.
Ha marcado esos dos goles de falta que no había marcado nunca en su carrera.
No es un futbolista del que vas a esperar un regate súper precioso.
Un tal.
Para mí creo que el término más bueno que bonito encaja mucho en ciertos perfiles
de centrocampista inglés histórico.
Porque creo que por ejemplo, Paul's Calls era buenísimo.
Pero precioso no era.
Joder, a mí es como...
Preciosista no era.
Sí, vale.
Pero es que es un tipo de distribuidor que solo con el golpeo de balón ya te lo...
Pero yo creo que...
Es que aquí vas a decir...
Joder, Steven Gerrard tenía una carrera rarísima.
Sí, es que era una acción que tenía, pero claro, a mí Gerrard me parecía...
Claro.
...juntamente bonito como le pegaba la pelota.
Claro, justo.
Que es verdad que esto igual descartaba también a Fede.
Porque la forma en la que Fede Valverde golpea la pelota, cuidado, eh.
Un golpeo precioso.
Oye, le estaba dando vueltas.
He ido al Palmares el balón de oro.
Y es cierto que no encuentro a ningún jugador especialmente feo.
A ver.
Es cierto que muchas veces es un concurso de popularidad.
Y la estética del futbolista está muy premiada.
Pero si me tuviera que quedar con uno,
está por ahí en los podios de 2002 y el 2003.
Pero en 2001 y 2002, el amigo Oliver Kahn.
Muy buena.
Justo.
Siendo portero, igual es el mejor ejemplo.
Me parecía que en porteros teníamos que abrir un melón,
porque también los hay, sí, sí.
Pero es muy complicado que los haya.
O sea, te quiero decir...
Bueno, Sergio Herrera puede ser un buen ejemplo de esto.
Además, era hasta feo.
¿Quién?
Oliver Kahn.
Ah, creo que vas a decir Sergio Herrera.
No, no, no.
Pero Sergio Herrera, como es tan divertido...
Claro.
¿Sabes?
Estoy viendo de los balones de oro...
Es que era muy feo.
¿Cuál es el balón de oro más feo?
¿Matías Sammers?
Te iba a decir Owen.
Owen...
Está muy rápido.
Owen, Owen.
Es un balón que tiene un tendente a la...
A la rudeza, ¿no?
A lo rústico en su juego.
Te lo digo, era muy simplón en ese sentido.
Muy bueno, evidentemente, pero muy...
No sé.
Pero luego ves aquí, claro, es que tienes a Titi Henry,
tienes a Gianluigi Bufon.
Estoy viendo en balón de plata y balón de bronce.
Bueno, Raúl.
Raúl era más bueno que bonito.
Pero yo hoy no compro tampoco con Raúl.
A mí Raúl me parece que...
No, pero este me pasa como con Luis Suárez, no.
Que no sea bonita la técnica de Raúl,
no significa que no sea técnico.
Raúl tiene una serie de definiciones.
Es que cuando pintan a Raúl como un empujado a balones,
sabes que no ha visto ni un partido de Raúl antes de 2003.
Eso es evidente.
Y realmente, cuando nos plantaste la idea del vídeo, Miguel,
mi cabeza se fue a Croacia 2018.
O sea, es que puedes meterla al que quieras.
Sí.
O sea, de Croacia 2018.
Versálico, Dómago y Vida,
Lobren...
Manjukic.
Manjukic es muy buena.
Anterevich, Perisic...
Bueno, Perisic parece de cajón.
Pero, perisic es bonito.
Rakitic y Modric, yo creo que no entrarían aquí.
Pero es que puedes coger un vídeo convocatoria.
En ese perfil de extremo se me ocurrió otro.
¿Cómo planteaste?
Muy voluntarioso, pero feo técnicamente.
Lucas Ocampos.
Sí.
Muy empeñado en el esfuerzo.
Sí, sí.
Siempre en mi equipo.
No, claro.
Pero no es el extremo más sabidoso.
A mí del perfil Perisic hay uno que me encantaba.
Que también juega en el Inter.
Que es Antonio Candreva.
Sí.
Yo de esa Italia...
Andrea molaba mucho.
¿Sabes con quién me quedo?
Con el que nos vacunó.
Gracias a Pele.
Con Graciano Pele.
Pero Pele era muy bonito, de verdad.
De espaldas era muy bueno.
Y además...
Alex...
Guapo.
La estética no la tiene bien calibrada.
Para mí...
Bueno, puede ser.
Por eso me parecéis todos muy guapos, la verdad.
Pero...
Hacía mucho que no lo hacía.
Espera.
No sabía.
En realidad...
Ah, bien.
No.
Lo que he dicho era más una...
¡Oh!
¡Me cago en el!
¡No!
Por favor, por favor.
Si puede quedar así todo el vídeo...
Es que es el momento perfecto de afearle la captura.
Increíble.
Porque además es como la...
Bueno, esto es lo que quieren ver todos los pibes.
Es la sonrisa completa de Miguel Quintana.
¡Ostras!
Sí, sí, sí, sí, sí.
¡Ay!
Pero estaba ahí completa, ¿eh?
Estaba ahí completa, macho.
Parecía... Era Ia, ¿no?
Ya estamos, ya estamos.
¡Cállate, que se me ve el foco!
Espérate.
Pero el foco...
¡El foco!
Ya está.
Alex, Alex.
Dí tu mejor ejemplo que tengas de jugador más bueno que bonito.
El que no podamos discutir ninguno de nosotros.
Peter Crouch.
Sí.
Sí, ¿no?
Parece que se iba a destartalar.
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Compro.
Es que es verdad que... ¿sabe lo que pasa?
Que...
Yo veo belleza donde no la hay.
Entonces...
Esto tiene una...
Me cuesta esta sección.
Eh... Eh... Eh...
Be... Eh... Belleza... Eh...
Esto tiene un nombre en el arte.
Eh...
Sí.
Hijo de la gran puta.
El poeta, eh.
El poeta que dice.
Pajó Dios y dijo...
Artista extracto.
Ese es el nombre.
No, no, pero tiene un nombre.
Pero para que no me...
Hace mucho que historia de arte...
¿Sabes cuál es ese nombre, Miguel?
Es...
José Luis Morales Nogales.
Gracias por dar el nombre.
¡Bua!
Yo siendo futbolista.
José Luis Morales.
O sea...
No, no.
A mí se me ocurrió...
Se me ocurrió también un centro campista.
Que lo hizo muy bien en el Barça.
Y en el Barça fue mucho más bueno que bonito.
Espera.
Espérate, espérate.
Reciente.
¿Reciente?
Sí, sí, sí.
¿Ricky?
No, no, no, no.
Como a ser Ricky Puch.
No, eh...
Pero puede ser Rakitic.
No.
Destacaba por su llegada al área.
¿Pauliño?
Pauliño.
Buzz, Pauliño, muy bueno.
Sí, a ver, bonito Pauliño.
Claro, no era.
No era.
Pero, oye...
Claro, es que yo en este perfil tenía un ejemplo muy, muy claro
que además ahora le venimos viendo en el Mundial de Clubes
o lo hemos visto en el Mundial de Clubes.
Samy Kedira.
De hecho, era tan feo que se le infravaloraba.
Porque era como...
Sí.
No, si no sabe jugar, no sabe...
¿Qué hace Samy Kedira?
La gente se pregunta ¿qué hace Samy Kedira?
Pero me parece...
No me parece el mejor de los ejemplos, Kedira.
Pues a mí me parece...
Me parece mucho más feo Casemiro, por ejemplo.
Casemiro...
Aquel Casemiro que había que apartar de la base de la jugada
porque no sabía controlar un balón y dar un pase.
Pero en el palo, en el auel, hay belleza.
Y todo esto.
Claro, claro.
En el tackle...
No, poca coña en esto, eh.
Cuando coje a Milner y lo revienta...
Vamos a ver.
Jace Milner sería un buen ejemplo.
Sí.
Más bueno que bonito.
La de Jace Milner es increíble.
Porque es el clásico vídeo...
Luego la gente dice, no, pero no vais de no sé qué, de pan en quita.
No, mira, esto es una competición.
Y siempre estando dentro del límite del reglamento.
Porque si la lias, te sacan roja y la has jodido.
Pero le han pegado un palo increíble a tu mejor jugadora,
y llega el otro con una falta que nunca puede ser roja,
pero que...
Sí, sí.
Que recuerdas unos días después y puso todo en orden.
Y, chicos...
Y Zidane, de fondo...
Es que eso es competir.
Alucinando.
Zidane alucino más con eso que con el goal de Bale.
Al hilo de lo que decía Alex con Crouch,
hay un central que es muy bueno,
pero siempre parece que se va a romper.
Siempre parece que se va a desmontar.
Sí.
Muy feo, muy feo.
Esa manera de correr.
Lo que va es que lo compensa con el toque a veces lúdico,
a veces sociópata.
Pero aquí no hemos hablado de divertimiento.
Sí, sí, sí.
Muy feo, muy feo jugador.
¿Me compráis en los llegadores Jean-Gel Herrera?
No.
¿En los jugadores de la serie?
¿Te parece bonito?
No, pero no me parece feo.
Pero tampoco feo, ¿no?
No lo podría calificar de feo.
Vale, vale.
Fíjate que en feos,
claro, no hemos calificado a futbolistas latinoamericanos casi, ¿no?
Pudiendo haber metido para la causa,
como decía Adri y todos los uruguayos,
que se nos podría ocurrir.
No, pero, por ejemplo,
Arevalo Ríos.
El ruso, el ruso, qué bueno era el ruso.
Gargano, ¿no?
Pero los buenos buenos,
solo te puedo comprar Edinson Cavani, si acaso.
Beforlan era bonito, Godin era bonito.
Cavani tiene goles preciosos.
Es que cuando está vinculado el gol,
es muy complicado no darle belleza.
Porque, por ejemplo, a mí se me había ocurrido Carlos Tevez.
Pero es que, claro...
Aquí influye un poquito el skin de Carlos Tevez, ¿no?
A ver, yo creo que delanteros que me den goles feos.
Hugo duro, Merentiel.
Merentiel es muy feo.
Es horrible.
Delantero empotrador.
El otro día me contaba...
Me puse un tuit de Merentiel
o le fiché en el fantasy del mundial de clubes
y me dice un miembro de una secretaría técnica.
¿De verdad te gusta Merentiel?
Joder, es que me gusta este típico delantero
que se lleva todo por el camino.
Y el ejemplo que puse es que me gusta Hugo duro.
O sea...
Es estético, no. Es bonito, no.
Pero es tremendamente productivo.
Llaman veces tremendamente esforzado.
¡Ah!
Larga vida de Ángel y me mata.
Ángel no es un buen ejemplo.
Ángel Rodríguez podría estar ahí.
No, Ángel molaba. No era feo.
Pero es que...
Adri, Adri, Adri.
Es que me has dicho...
Ángel molaba.
No digo que no mole. Mola.
Pero feo no era con el desmarquero.
Pero si digo que es...
Imagínate, Adri, Adri.
Tú pagas...
Hacen un espectáculo interactivo
en el que te muestran los cien jugadores más bonitos de la liga.
Vale.
Y tú de repente llegas, ¿vale?
Y en lugar del primer set, me invento, Neymar...
Te sale Ángel Rodríguez.
Y tú vas a decir...
Y a mi, ¿no?
Va en orden alfabético, ¿no?
Exacto.
A ver, si dices que es el jugador más bonito de la liga, sí que no.
En la liga hay un ejemplo muy claro que es...
muy feo y muy bueno.
Es el pirata.
Mirichi.
¿Y Kike? ¿Kike García?
Sí, es que ese perfil de nueve...
Es que ese perfil de nueve es muy proclive a eso.
Claro, claro.
Ellos no van a darle belleza a nada.
Ellos van a hacer faena.
Hay un caso que creo que es muy raro.
O sea, lateral, ofensivo, ¿vale?
Y que sea más feo que bueno.
O sea, más bueno que bonito.
En la liga.
Es que es creativo, es ofensivo, pero es feo.
Sabalí.
Ratxiu.
A mí Ratxiu me parece el caso.
No, pero si empieza a tirar ahí ruletas y todo.
Pero Ratxiu se va chocando con las cosas.
Claro, pero no es natural.
Claro, pero es muy bueno.
Ratxiu es un poco Suárez en eso de llevarse la pelota tras tabilla,
pero llevarse la... Tiene una ruleta en otras peras...
No sé.
¿Quién sería el jugador...?
Rambal tiene un poquito de eso.
¿Quién sería el jugador de la liga que se llevaría ante más obstáculos la pelota sí o sí?
Ahora que has planteado eso.
Bueno, Diego Costa en su momento, que también podría venir aquí.
Ah, mira, tengo un nombre.
Y se llevaría el balón en la liga.
Piña que Williams.
Sí, está bien tirado.
Muy buena.
En esa pregunta, ¿no se la llevaría Samu Costa?
Hombre...
No, pero es que Samu Costa...
Samu Costa se lleva la...
Como el rodo de un gerente.
O sea, su labor es ser feo.
Se lleva la pelota, se lleva el casco, la gorra...
Yo creo que quiere que él es Samu Costa y lleva el balón. Ni lo intento.
En defensas feos pero muy buenos, Giorgio Chiellini.
Me parece muy obvio en su momento.
Bueno, yo creo que los de la BBC...
Pero Bonucci era bonito con la serie de balón.
Y la Sarli...
Yo de hecho, el que tenía puntadas es a Nacho.
Sí, sí.
Es que siempre cumple, ¿no?
La categoría es como complicada, ¿no?
Yo tengo uno muy polémico, Alex.
Muy, muy polémico.
Oye, ¿y Puyol?
Puyol sí.
¿Y la ruleta Ucrania en el Mundial 2006?
Pero claro...
Claro, es que que se celebrase tanto era porque la había hecho Puyol.
Si la hace Gerard Piqué...
Es como el Peralti de Mascherano con el Barça.
A ver, es buenísimo.
A ver.
Buenísimo.
Pero para ser tan bueno, siendo extremo ofensivo, encalador...
Me parece más bueno que bonito.
Bukayo Saka.
O sea, ¿qué decir?
Enicius me sorprende con regates.
Y le veo más...
O sea, me divierte más.
Bukayo Saka...
El concepto no es divertirme.
O sea, qué bueno es.
Bukayo Saka es para ti un funcionario.
O sea, él tiene que llevar la pelota del punto A al punto B.
Y si puede, desde el punto B, meterla, la va a meter.
Realmente, para mí, el ejemplo de...
En cierto medio, sí.
En ese perfil de futbolista, para mí, el ejemplo es Rafinha.
Sí.
Está bien tirado.
Es...
Porque no es tan brasileño como tenemos en la cabeza.
Claro.
Claro, claro. Y es verdad que...
Pero es, de nuevo, el perfil de delantero esforzado.
Y en estos casos tiene trampa de que tú coges el golpeo de Bukayo Saka o el de Rafinha.
Y claro, no puedes decir que es feo.
Pero es lo que habéis dicho, que el jugador que tiene gol...
Es raro que te pueda entrar en esta categoría.
Y es algo que sea ese típico delantero que te baja lavadoras.
A mí me queda uno ya.
Mira, a mí... Y a mí me queda otro.
A mí se me ocurrió una categoría con esto.
Que es...
Fútbolistas que no te esperes que sean tan bonitos.
Que sean tan técnicos.
Que para mí, por ejemplo, el caso que representaría muy bien eso es Berbatov.
Sí.
Uno de los mejores primeros toques que hemos visto en la élite.
Y el tío, tú lo ves y de la ortega, un delantero para rematar en el área y tal.
Y luego no.
Y el físico que tenía que era un poquito...
No era súper profesional, me parece.
No, no, no. Pero ahora está súper fino, ¿eh?
Era buenísimo de mitad. Buenísimo.
Ahora está súper fino porque además fue muy gracioso.
Se jugó un partido en Ultrafort que era de leyendas, no sé qué.
Y eran Berbatov y Wijnrune.
Claro, en su momento era uno súper enorme y el otro súper fino.
Al revés.
Wijnrune nunca ha estado súper fino, pero más pequeñito.
Y ahora es al revés.
Andy Lucas se han invertido los roles.
En esa categoría que dice Álex, encajaría el Raúl Jiménez previo al golpe.
Sí.
No lo se venecen los golpes a un delantero muy molón.
Y no esperabas que hiciese tantas cosas como hacía.
Sí, es muy de delantero grandote que luego técnicamente es mucho más fino.
Bueno, Voltemade.
Voltemade.
Es un poco eso de...
Ezeco también es un poco ese flow.
Sí, Ezeco, exactamente.
Vale, ¿nos queda un nombre a cada uno?
Sí.
Vale, lo cerramos. Empezamos contigo, Adri.
Marco Curella.
Muy bueno.
Buenísimo, de hecho.
Muy bueno, pero...
Pero ya lo había dicho, ¿no?
No, yo no lo he sacado.
Se viene la broma.
¡Bullón!
Ahí está.
¡Cállate!
¡Estás tocando como un becerro!
¡No, no, no!
No, no. Si no lo he dicho, no lo he dicho.
¡Yo lo he dicho!
Venga.
Tu nombre.
Mucha gente cree que no se juega a fútbol y no tiene ni puta idea.
Pablo.
Pablo Páez Gavira.
Gaby.
Creo que representa...
Buena esta.
Yo, de hecho, doy mi último nombre
porque va en relación al de Gaby.
Fermín.
A mí Fermín me parece eso.
O sea, ojo, me apunta.
Como muy industrial, muy dinámico,
muy intenso, con un gran golpe de balón.
Pero incluso en el Balón de Oro de los Juegos Olímpicos,
que es un torneo acojonante,
es como efectividad pura.
O sea, nada de cara a la galería,
¿no?
Y todo a producir.
Que es un poco el concepto.
Y me parece que va en la línea de lo de Gaby.
Tu último nombre, Álex de Llano.
Tienes la oportunidad, ¿vale?
Para cerrar por todo lo alto o por todo lo bajo.
Y conociéndote, y conociéndote...
Que no tenga ningún sentido.
... y conociéndote sé lo que vas a hacer.
Verás.
Es que además no lo he dicho porque digo,
bueno, no me tocará el último,
pero me ha tocado el último.
Y mi nombre es...
Este es... Habéis visto... Perdón, Álex.
Habéis visto alguna vez el meme este de un chaval
que está en el patio y le viene un balón,
están jugando al fútbol a lo lejos y le viene un balón
botando y lo tiene que devolver.
Con un golpeo sencillito.
Pues coge el balón y lo chuta
a tomar por...
Lo saca del colegio.
Esto le pasó
a nuestro compañero amigo Javi Valle.
Creo que era el valladolid rayo
que le cae un balón
y entonces se lo tiene que devolver a James Rodríguez
y tú dices, ¡guay!
Le voy a dar un pase a James, ¿sabes?
Petacular, tal, no sé qué más.
Y le manda el pase a...
A Isaac.
Tal cual.
Mi nombre es...
Michael Balak.
Bueno.
O sea, para hacer tu final
es poco de Llanesco.
Es que, a ver, es que claro...
Para mí no era súper...
O sea, no era súper bonito.
Para mí era un jugador industrial,
como lo has dicho tú de Fermín, ¿no?
¡Venga, va, venga!
Así de vuelta, pim pam, pim pam, pim pam, pim pam.
El y el amigo Bastion.
¿Y el jugador de la franquicia?
Sí, Bastion es muy buena.
Bastion además es...
Bastion tenía...
Ah, mira, mira, mira, mira.
Se me acaba de ocurrir. De Alemania.
Odonkor.
Esto es más de Llanesco.
O sea, decir que Odonkor era más bueno que bonito,
o sea, no era ninguna de las dos.
Pero, pero si tuvieras que coger algo...
¡No!
Dejo un melón para los pizarritas.
Nosotros no lo respondemos, pero dejo un melón.
Vale.
¿En esta categoría
entraría...
el bicho?
No.
Imposible. Pero vamos, o sea, Miguel.
O sea, vas a ver. Es que no, no, imposible.
Me parece que el vídeo de los triples va a salir más tarde.
No.
Va a salir en otro momento. Pero es más bueno que bonito.
Yo es que creo,
yo es que creo, Miguel, que tú
en... Yo no sé qué
fútbol veías en 2005,
en 2006...
Pues más que tú. Más que tú,
que tenías ocho años. Porque, hermano...
Sí, pero tú no veías el vídeo del
Reyano, el mítico vídeo del
Reyano, elreyano.net,
elreyano.com, ya no me acuerdo.
A ver cómo veis el fútbol en aquella época.
Que era de regate, que eran videos
de regate. Sí.
Un par de rovillas de Santos, no eran todos de Cristiano.
Sí, pero que en 2005
han pasado veinte años.
Miguel, yo creo que
en ese plano que tienes tú, no sale
la planta de la marihuana.
Tú, amigo Miguel Quintana,
tú fumas porros.
Hasta aquí. Si no me lo compráis,
no me lo compráis.